one of the big ongoing misconceptions we
have is that sex might be something that
happens in our bodies when it is of
course overwhelmingly an intellectual
business rooted in the mind perhaps
nothing proves this so well as the
business of sexting highly creative
activity in which two people who may be
on opposite continents from one another
can nevertheless to the share medium of
words bring each other off without so
much as a single touch of the skin like
any good writer
the sexter must create profound effects
in another's mind merely through the
manipulation of the alphabet though that
the goal is also to provoke orgasm
arguably places a demand for visceral
literary talent almost as great as that
required by a National Book Award or
Pulitzer Prize errata sysm emerges first
and foremost from the pleasure in which
relief plays a huge part at having our
secret sexual selves witnessed endorsed
and encouraged by a kindly other the
good sexter knows how to call forth the
otherwise shamed shy parts of their
partner and to lead them to lay aside
the punishing propriety that society
normally demands so-called dirty words
have an important role to play in
successful texting for their taboo
nature functions as evidence
loyalty and Trust we can save polite
things - more or less
anyone but it's only around someone
rather special that we can at last spill
out the plethora of extreme things that
we've known since childhood we must
never utter they may sound like the
opposite of tenderness but the dirtiest
words are in fact touching symbols of
loyalty and emotional intimacy
they are evidence that we've at last
found someone to whom we can reveal our
true wayward selves without guilt in the
heat of texting we no longer have to
care about being those rather oppressive
titles a good boy or a nice girl while
the city sleeps swearwords insults
extreme longings all travel down
oblivious fiber-optic cables
orbiting satellites will eavesdrop on
the details of fantasies of cunnilingus
what our phone companies were later in a
month
discreetly referred to as nearly data
bears the imprint of excited journeys
from loneliness to the deepest intimacy
it's no more fair to dismiss texting
because many people have done it without
artistry than to dismiss all works of
literature because they've been so many
substandard bucks sexting awaits
rediscovery is a supreme medium of
literary talent an honest and poignant
communication
you
you